Transcriber: Tom Carter
Reviewer: Bedirhan Cinar
Doctor 1: So, how did it get
to be this way?
Doctor 2: Well, it’s my professional
opinion that the large gaping bite mark
on its shoulder might have something
to do with it.
D1: Thanks. I mean, what causes
its behavioral abnormalities?
D2: Well, we know all behaviors
are rooted in the brain,
so I’d expect that something’s gone
terribly wrong, probably in there.
D1: Thanks again, Doctor Obvious.
Let me be more specific.
What changes in the brain
would have to occur
in order to cause this kind of behavior?
D2: Hmm. Well, let's see.
The first thing I notice is how it moves.
Stiff legged, with long, lumbering steps,
very slow and awkward.
Almost like what you’d see
in Parkinson’s disease.
Maybe something’s wrong
with his basal ganglia?
Those are a collection of deep brain
regions that regulate movement,
through a neurochemical called dopamine.
Although most people think of dopamine
as the “happy” chemical of the brain,
the dopamine-containing neurons
in the basal ganglia
die off in Parkinson’s disease—
that’s what causes it.
Makes it more and more difficult
to initiate actions.
D1: What?
Look again at how it moves.
Stiff legs, long stance.
These aren’t Parkinsonian movements;
Parkinson’s patients take
short, shuffling steps.
And the posture’s all wrong.
This looks to me like what happens
when the cerebellum is damaged.
The cerebellum’s a little cauliflower
shaped area in the back of your head,
but don’t let its size fool you.
That little guy contains almost half
of the neurons in the entire brain.
Patients who suffer degeneration
from this region,
something called spino-cerebellar ataxia,
show a lack of coordination that results
in stiff legs, wide stance,
and a lumbering walk.
My money's on the cerebellum.
D2: Touché. OK.
So we’ve nailed its motor problems.
Now what about that whole groaning,
lack of talking thing?
D1: Hmm.
You know, it sounds kind of like
expressive aphasia, or Broca’s aphasia,
which makes producing words difficult.
This is caused by damage
to the inferior frontal gyrus,
or possibly the anterior insula,
both regions behind your temple
on the left side of your head.
D2: I think you’re only half right.
Zombies definitely can’t communicate,
that’s for sure.
But they don’t seem to do a good job
of understanding things either.
Watch this. Hey, Walker!
Your father smelt of elderberries!
See? No reaction.
Either it’s not a Monty Python fan,
or it can’t understand me.
I’d say this is like spot-on fluent
Wernicke’s aphasia:
damage to an area at the junction
of two of the brain’s lobes,
temporal and parietal,
typically on the left side of the brain,
is the culprit.
This area is physically connected
to Broca’s area, that you mentioned,
by a massive bundle of neurofibers
called the arcuate fasciculus.
I hypothesize that this massive bundle
of connections
is completely wiped out in a zombie.
It would be like taking
out the superhighway between two cities.
One city that manufactures a product,
and the other that ships it
out to the rest of the world.
Without that highway,
the product distribution just shuts down.
D1: So, basically it’s a moot point
to reason with a zombie,
since they can’t understand you,
let alone talk back.
D2: I mean, you could try, man,
but I’m going to stay
on this side of the glass.